now when I look at you and look at
myself in the mirror I see certain
traits when I look at the universe why
am I here what's my purpose you get like
everything you're wearing now your
jacket your shoes you know do you have
shoes my shoes Sor yeah okay yeah I was
going to say I was going to say your
shoes
[Music]
we want to establish an amazing Masid
for the sake of Allah subhana in the
country of Norway click on the link and
donate now for the sake of Allah subhana
tala yeah what's your name sister anun
anun nice name what does that mean is
name I don't think so a surname I'm
Angola you're
what Central America next to gu wow wow
interesting okay I heard from I'm
Kurdish from Turkey oh okay nice Mar
yeah
Mar okay so um I'll use a couple of
arguments I'm just thinking where which
argument I can use to prove that God
exists now let's okay I'll make it
simple yeah you see that picture there
yeah okay let's suppose that's a
painting yeah now by looking at that
painting there is a lot of things that I
can know about the painter okay number
one I know that he exists number two I
know that he will to paint that number
three I know he's good at what he does
he's artistic you know he's Innovative
he's intelligent by looking at that
painting there's so many attributes that
I can give to the person who painted
that now when I look at you and look at
myself in the mirror I see certain
traits when I look at the universe okay
I know that there is information in the
universe for example you are made out of
atoms and uh DNA so do you know that DNA
has information in it okay a single
strand of D DNA they say has more
information than every single book now
if there's information it requires
intelligence so we say that as Muslims
that we believe that the Universe began
to exist if the universe began to exist
some being gave rise to it it has the
attribute of will it will the universe
to come to be now we accept that if
there's information in the universe the
the being that created it has to be the
all knowing now number two would you
accept that there's energy there's power
in the universe good so he has to be the
all powerful yeah just as the picture we
have to give these attributes number
three would you accept that there is
evil in the universe evil evil that's
good and bad yeah then he has to be the
old wise because there are certain
things that we see as bad that does not
make sense to us so he has to have
wisdom behind why those things are
happening so in the Quran Allah tells us
that you might hate something which is
good for you and you might love
something which is bad for you so this
life is a test and certain things might
happen that we don't understand but
there's a wisdom behind it good also
because there's evil he has to be the
most just because he has to take these
people to account for example King Leon
Leon leopard II he went to Congo and
killed 10 million conges people yeah a
lot of people talk about the Holocaust
which is bad as well but nobody talks
about this in Congo he killed 10 million
people what's going to happen to this
person is he just going to die in like
if when we say agnosticism if there is
some kind of a being that being has to
be the most just we can't we to say that
he's just there what's his what's his
role we can't say his energy he has to
have those attributes like I said the
will power knowledge wise these
attributes has to be given to him now
when we give these attributes to him we
say that has to be God Almighty because
there is an active will that's taking
part in agnosticism it's like there's
something there I don't know what it is
so it's going from deism to theism
you're more of a d you're saying I
believe there's something there but I'm
saying you need to make that more
personal and there's evidence that that
you become a the that would be my
argument there's many arguments I give
there's DNA there's the fact that you're
design your eyes your heart you know uh
atoms I can talk about many stuff but I
don't know if that convinces
you it's given me something to process
and to think about um but I have had
this conversation people before so it's
not a first but like I think more more
than anything I think especially when it
comes to per say Christians that have
had this conversation with the first
instant is to attack me and it's never
to really break things down to me in a
way where I can fully understand cu the
thing is I haven't been agnostic on my
life I actually grew up um as a member
of the je witness congregation so it's
the thing where I guess coming out of
that there was a lot that I was taught
that I felt like I had to break within
myself and after coming out of that no
one's ever sat me down like in a
conversation and actually taking the
time to um answer the questions that
I've had and even if they had a lot of
the answers that they had were like
pointed towards faith and when you don't
have that you don't have anything else
good so this is very interesting in the
Quran Allah subhana t god almighty tells
us there's a certain verse in Surah Al
Imran yeah Allah says indeed in the
creation of the heavens and the Earth
and in the alternation of the night and
day there are signs for those who have
intellect in Islam we don't have this
Blind Faith concept like you speak a lot
of Christians and we say to them the
Trinity doesn't make sense yeah Jesus
never claimed to be divine the Holy
Spirit or whatever God cannot be a man
they say yeah but we don't understand
have faith what do you mean by have
faith why do you cross time I don't
understand why you're bringing that up's
not yeah the reason I'm bringing it up
is because she said that because she was
Jehovah's Witnesses before and it's um
it was all about faith I'm saying that
Christians have a lot of faith but in
the Book of James it says faith with no
works is dead so meaning that we can't
just have faith that's why I was just
mentioning Christianity that's the
reason I didn't I didn't mean to like
offend anybody in that way that's why
saying as a Muslim we are told to use
our intellect so we need to question I
can't just be like I came to Islam Liv
years ago 13 years ago I was your
typical western party and clubing all
that kind I had to come me every week so
the thing is I had to come to a
realization and say to myself okay why
am I here what's my purpose you get like
everything you're wearing now your
jacket your shoes you know do you have
shoes my shoes are my sorry yeah okay
yeah I was going to say I was going to
say shoes you haveo shoes and and and we
need to and we need to we need to come
to that as well I'm gon to make it I'm G
to make a point about why you don't have
shoes on yet let me guess let me guess
the heels are hurting your feet exactly
there's a book you need to buy called
Beauty sck okay I'll come to that later
that's a whole different discuss I'll be
reading it's a very interesting book
here so what I'm saying is as Muslims
you need to use your brain you need to
think and say hold on a second that's
why God Almighty tells us in the Quran
you think Ponder you know look at things
so that's why I'm not here to Doom you
and Gloom you and you're going to the
fire we don't we're not our religion
doesn't teach us to throw people into
the Hellfire do you get it our religion
is a religion of mercy and I'm not
saying it's lot people come and say oh
Islam is just about peace it's not just
about peace you get what I'm trying to
saying of course there's aspects of
Defending yourself and War but in
totality in the Quran every single
chapter except one talks about God
Almighty the most merciful the very
merciful Allah repeats this um attribute
about himself he's the most merciful the
very merciful why because God Almighty
wants a relationship with his with his
creation he's not a monster who's like I
want people to go hell he wants people
to enter Paradise he wants you to have a
relation with him a lot of Christians
when they leave the faith they think ah
Islam is probably the same it's not a
lot of people have this thing or like oh
Islam is just another religion it's
small if you read it the Quran is the
only scripture that hasn't been changed
the Quran is the only scripture that
challenges you and says if you think
this is not from your lord bring a
chapter like it or find contradictions
and errors I have got two Bibles the
King James version and I've Got The New
International Version I read it there
are passages taken out and my question
is who are these who's written this
stuff if it's been written by men so
that's why like you know I know you have
the experience but as as Muslims in
Islam we believe you have one
relationship with God Almighty a
personal relationship you don't need to
go through prophet Muhammad Jesus Moses
you have a direct relationship with God
Almighty number two the Quran has been
sent down as the final Testament you
have the Old Testament you have the New
Testament and you have the final
Testament we don't believe the scripture
that they have today is preserved we
believe the original gospel that was
given to Jesus is what we what we
believe in so yeah in show that um like
that's that's that's our belief you know
but have you read the Quran before I
have um when I was actually working with
I was working with a group of people who
um practiced Islam yeah back in 2022 and
this was I want to say like 3 four years
after come completely come out of the
religion that was in previously and the
first time i' actually prayed since
coming out was actually with a Muslim
brother and honestly it moved me to
tears because it wasn't that I felt what
he was feeling but I think it was more
of a thing where I really appreciated
the beauty of like having that faith in
someone cuz like I guess being being
agnostic is more of a thing where you
have a series of questions I guess for
atheist they are so firm in their
beliefs which is you know I'm not I
don't know if the big bra theory is
simply just a theory of what they
believe in butly they're confident in
their their beli and obviously there's a
series of other people also conf belev
and obviously I feel like I'm not
comfortable in anything so I guess but
you want answers I and those answers
should be given to you that's why it's
very important to have dialogue and
discussion so like if you have any
questions I believe there's multiple
evidences to go from theism to theism
because it only makes sense that the God
Almighty that created us had a will all
of this is there is like Allah says in
the Quran he did not create this for
play it's not it's not like oh we just
just play a game no it's not because
that creator has to be cannot a purpose
this Creator because everything that we
have here has a purpose everything you
look at now the camera the the shoes in
your bag yes everything has a purpose so
the thing is how can I come and say
everyone that invented something your
bag your shoes whatever my jacket they
gave they're they're the designer of
that thing they gave it a purpose and he
has a design but the one who created the
universe it can't be because there's
order there's we have laws of uh gravity
we have stability uniformity regularity
that's what we science I don't pick up a
bottle of water and it turns into an
elephant so we have order if there's
order there has to be an order maker so
that's why I believe I'm sure you will
believe as well that there has to be a
Creator not some energy it has to be you
know but yeah if you have any questions
ask me feel free I mean don't feel I'm
not offended about anything have a
channel yes my name is Ali dawa um on
YouTube YouTube yeah so videos this
video might go up there so I
might yes yes is this the app or the
YouTu yeah
okay so right now we are
uh have any conversations you've had
with people like I do I do a lot but
like I I prefer like having sincere
discussions you know but I'm I'm quite
active sorry I put the
[Music]
wrong
yeah yeah this it we're also live so
you'll probably see yourself now okay
let me see I don't know if this yeah
there you go okay yeah but but um this
is live but I have this will be
pre-recorded I'll put it up yeah do you
have any questions no okay regarding
regarding Just One Last Thing regarding
your your uh heel do you mind if I can
look at
your I just want to look at the this is
very important yeah cuz I'm going to
make a very uh strong point they're
actually nice heels yeah no I've got no
problem with the heels okay look that's
what is this is it like 5 in I've got no
idea okay look I need you to buy this
book here it's called Beauty sick I'll
give that back to you thank you much now
the thing is this Islam if we look at
Society the the book Beauty sick is
actually talks about that a lot of a lot
of women are under the impression that
and women men and women as well the
impression that they are they are
willingly and choosing to wake up and
spend two hours doing make up getting
their hair done wearing heels look these
things of course a woman likes to Ador
herself but you know it's uncomfortable
walking in those Hills but you need to
understand would you accept that for me
to say peer pressure the beauty industry
and many other factors play a role
because you know why I was in your shoes
a long time ago I used to have a
specific jumper that I believe I look
good in I mean people might differ with
that but that's was my I believe that
and this jumble was a material that
would it was itchy material but I used
to wear it because I believed I looked
good in it now I asked myself a question
I was like when I came to Islam I
thought to myself I'm wearing a jumper
that I am uncomfortable in but I am
wearing it because I believe I look good
in same thing with women who wear heels
same with women who are walking with
minis skirts Inus 5° because they look
good in it they're making no
sacrifices I thought to myself you know
what I'm actually a slave this jumper is
my master because I'm in obedience to it
and I thought to myself true freedom is
what that as woman the Western Society
has reduced women to a sexual object so
Islam has come to tell the woman that
she has more to offer than her beauty so
that's the reason why Islam tells a
woman and it's a test for them as well
that they should cover up now there is
this misconception that as if Muslims
believe that just because a man can't
control himself a woman should cover up
that's not true as a man I am told that
I have to lower my gaze not look even if
the woman is dressed up in a bikini or
covered up fully my job is to not look
in that way to lower my gaze so would
you accept that the fact that you know
you having to put your heels away walk
with your socks on yeah plays a factor
in that would you say that there are
peer pressures indirect peer pressures
playing a role that making you feel that
you need to look a certain way or wear a
certain clothing that you believe you
look good in no and the only reason say
that is because sometimes I have this
conversation with my mom where she would
ask me uh she she might question some of
my outfit choices and obviously like
you've mentioned when girls are wearing
minis skirts it's because of that
validation that they get from going
outside but for me I always thinking
myself it's like if I was the only
person left in the world I'll either be
naked cuz there's no one else to judge
me in my clothing or whatever or i'
really wear whatever I want to wear I
feel like I feel like it would be more
taboo for me to be walking around with
socks than it would be for me to being
heals now my heels yes they are
uncomfortable and they are painful but
at the end of the day if I really truly
wanted to sacrifice my pain in order to
continue feeling that level of
validation would kept my heels on and I
think another another thing in regards
to that as well a lot of people have a
sense of Pride for maybe for like
another girl who is in Hill she might
also want to sacrifice um you know
feeling uncomfortable because she might
fear other people looking at her and
questioning whether she's even able to
walk in Hills at all um so I think for
me it purely is a personal thing cuz I
can wear heels I I wear heels because I
like them because I like them we we
wouldn't deny that for example a woman
would look good in heels the thing is
though I believe that it come to a point
where it hurts your feet so much where
you're like I actually do not care what
people think just take and like for you
to just take I'll be honest with like of
course cuz you're more comfortable like
this but do you not feel like you know I
had that peer pressure there's things
that people think like you make
decisions but how do you make decisions
when you are told what to think like the
beauty industry puts a great emphasis on
woman's body that makes feel less more
uglier they look a certain way you have
to wear this you have to wear that and
this is made that's why the book I
recommended you it talks about girls who
eat yogurt every fre4 hours not to pass
out so they can have the perfect body
yeah but that's only for those that feel
pressured by societal pressures but I
consider myself an individual who is
almost 100% confident within themselves
so I can go my hair not done no makeup
on no nothing and I wouldn't care and I
guess a part of that might also be due
to the fact that many people have also
validated me enough when I was when I'm
not in this state to the point where I
also feel comfortable when I'm not in
this state so I guess that's also one
aspect but I guess obviously I get that
that applies to so many women but obious
you're having a conversation with me and
as an individual I don't feel
uncomfortable okay good so you're so
then I can say you know what you're one
of those strong charactered individuals
but not many women are like you and many
women fall like for example like you
said I can come and agree and say you
know what you are a rare case which is
very unique but there are so many women
who are peer pressured one way or
another through moving Netflix social
media the beauty industry I mean there
was a Brazilian woman who got but
impants and she passed away people are
becoming Martyrs at the at the risk of
beauty people so there's such a great
emphasis given on beauty that the book
talks about the woman she was doing a
study she said I was I was so shocked by
the results I wanted to stop the study
because so many women were like if I was
not only judged by my beauty and looks I
would focus more on my education I would
focus more on some of my family members
so there's a massive emphasis given by
the beauty industry to make females feel
they have to look a certain way they
more and there was one woman there she
said I felt so unattractive that I would
go and sleep around with men for
validation and I thought to myself that
is the biggest oppression and
enslavement of wom around the world cuz
a women come and say oh you guys oppress
your woman by wearing the hijab but I'm
like okay how many women are oppressed
by wearing the hijab but how many women
go outside and they they they do not
feel comfortable there was a study done
you know when the co thing happened you
have to wear mask they found out that
woman were carrying on wearing the mask
when they was not obligatory and they
asked him why they said because I can go
out without putting makeup on and I
don't need to be judged so that's the
the factor in there but I'm like I'm
happy to see that you're a strong
character and I think Islam I believe
you know I can even see you as being a
Muslim I can see have considered it I
lie to you have consider what's Stu in
your sister I think it's purely just the
fact that I don't have enough faith and
I I recognize that faith is something
that I need to work on as Faith but you
also Islam has answers of course it has
answers but I don't even think I think
another layer to that is also the life
I'm currently living living now and I
don't know what side outweighs what but
I also recognize that the life I'm
currently living now I'm not ready to
give up yet and maybe when I am you know
I might seek Islam and stuff like that
but I recognize in myself that I'm very
comfortable with the life I live with
now and I recognize that joining not
joining but um becoming you know Muslim
means making sacrifices so means leaving
a lot of things that I practice now and
I don't think there's a I'm willing or
ready to make as a well okay all right
but the the thing you need to bear in
mind is I was where you was about 13 14
years ago um same thing I would be
indulged in sins and whatever for that
matter and I thought to myself I was in
double mind like you get like I was like
I'm I'm sinning so if I become a Muslim
but I'm going to be a sinner but the
biggest misconception is that Islam is
not looking for Saints Islam is for the
Sinners Paradise is full of Sinners why
because Islam is not looking for
Perfection it's not asking you to be a
sa it's not for the Saints it's for the
people who sin so that's why even like
for example we are told that there's is
like a the Saints of the Prophet
Muhammad God Almighty said if mankind
was not to sin I will destroy them and
bring forth a nation that sins but
repents so God does not want us to be
sinless he rather wants us to be
individuals who observe him who have a
relation with him and repent so don't
think that because I'm a sinner I cannot
become a Muslim yes you can it's if you
want to stop the sin or gradually
becoming a Muslim is that first step so
there's many Muslims who commit sins
there Muslims that out here clubing
partying drinking doing all kind of
stuff they are still a Muslim because
they believe God is one they believe the
Quran is the final message and the
prophet mammad is the final Prophet so
don't let that stop you from you I've
considered that but I think for me it's
also a thing where I have seen many
Muslim sisters who you know when you ask
them what are you say I'm Muslim and
they might even be going around wearing
the hij but for me when they're doing
things that I think aren't just or
aren't right in the eyes of Allah for me
I guess it kind of rubs me the wrong way
and I completely understand that what
those sisters are doing is what they are
doing
but lie act it from theth because
whatever those sisters are doing is just
based on them but I guess for me when I
sort of flip the script B I also think
about myself and I think about the
things that I'm doing now and if I was
to go around and you know start telling
people you know I'm Islam or I'm Muslim
um or even start wearing the hijab and
stuff I don't ever want my actions to
ever be a representation of okay that's
that's that's that's such a beautiful
thing you said you know why because what
you said is so profound because you're
basically saying I don't want to become
a Muslim yet because I do not believe I
can represent it in the right way that's
really beautiful but there's the hand of
Satan there because what it's doing to
you is a following it's basically
telling you okay yes and this is what
how Satan comes to you like we believe
Satan comes to you and says who created
this and you're like God who created
that God who created this God who
created God oh my who created God so
Satan comes in ways to show you things
and you're like oh my gosh like what you
said is such a profound thing such a
beautiful thing actually the concept in
itself is I want to represent My
Religion if I'm going to become a Muslim
in the best way however Satan adds in
there yeah that's true you see you've
got such good intentions you're not
ready for Islam yet so we need to take
that bit out do you get it which is the
following you becoming a Muslim does not
mean you need to wear the hijab
instantly so I'm just saying if you
become a Muslim sister it's a gradual
process so there are many people who
come to Islam they are still cing they
drink alcohol but the main thing is what
for you to have a relationship with God
Almighty because if you die in a state
of disbelief knowing Islam is the truth
you can be in trouble but what we're
saying is that obviously that's if you
know Islam is the truth so you feel like
yeah so to me is that don't let that
stop you or deter you from becoming a
Muslim because if that's the case I
should not be a Muslim because I sin
till this day you know I'm I'm a public
figure you know they see me as a
religious figure I sin you what I'm
trying to say God does not want you to
be sinless so the conent is beautiful
but know that the hand of Satan is there
so you becoming a Muslim is just
testifying and then on that Journey so I
don't obviously I don't know if you're
ready yourself but to testify that God
is one there's nothing worth worthy of
worship except Allah the prophet
Muhammad is the final messenger you
become a Muslim and then your journey
starts so if you truly believe that you
can do it yourself you can take a
shahada it's called a shahada the
testimony of faith and just start your
journey take a step at the
time I'm not ready to believe those and
I know it but I feel that you know when
I am I feel like I know
me forever that's good so I'm actually
very grateful that you were able
to just s teach NOK sister we're here
that's fine we're here every Friday and
Sunday your friends having fun yeah
we're here every Friday and Sunday if
you have any questions come visit us oh
we're here every Friday and Sunday okay
Friday after 5 but Sunday after two
we're here so please come visit us if
you have any questions this is our job
this is what we do so feel free if you
come and see you brother Ali I've got
this question this question this
question I want to know about this this
this this this it's good our job is to
do this so yeah and you can watch my
YouTube videos and there might be some
of them that you
can thank you sister was nice talking to
you God bless
you the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam said whoever builds a Masid for
the sake of Allah subhana tala Allah
will build for him a similar house in
jenah on that day where Allah subh tala
tells us that our books will be given
and every little atam weight of Good
Deed you've done will be there and
imagine IM you see a mountain and you're
like what a lucky person which righteous
person and Allah says this is for you
for me yes what did I do you allowed
people to pray you built a Masjid I
never had the money to build a Masjid oh
Allah you helped you gave towards it and
Allah gives you the reward of as if you
built it donate now guys and do not
delay and share the video for extra
Rewards
[Music]